[Music]
it is an honor to join you this morning
for this special occasion
it is also an honor to speak to you
today from behind this gigantic tree
sound like some sort of female Lorax
with an advanced degree mindy kaling
dropping all the jokes during her
dartmouth commencement speech over the
weekend but it wasn't all fun and games
the 38 year old alum also opened up
about being a single mother to daughter
Catherine after my daughter was born in
December I remember bringing her at home
and being in my house with her for the
first time and thinking huh according to
movies and TV this is traditionally the
time when my mother and spouse are
supposed to be here sharing this
experience with me and I looked around
and I hadn't either but maybe was quick
to point out that she wouldn't trade the
experience for the world the joy I feel
from being from being with my daughter
Catherine eclipses anything from any
crazy checklist I didn't think I'd had a
child before I got married but hey it
turned out that way and I wouldn't
change a thing
as for the oceans eight stars of final
words of wisdom for the class of 2018 if
you have a checklist good for you
structured ambition and sometimes be
motivating but also feel free to let it
go yes my culminating advice for my
speech is a song from the Disney
animated movie frozen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]